[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
spatiotemporal characterization and
quantification of dna replication events
by molecular coming
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by genomic vision to learn more
visit genomicvision.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
cindy for sda scientific account manager
at genomic vision
cindy you may now begin your
presentation
so good morning everyone my name is
cindy forestier and i am scientific
account manager for genomic vision and
today i am going to present you how
molecular combine technology with
genomic vision replication combing assay
rca
enables spatial temporal
characterization and quantification of
dna replication events for a better
understanding of replication kinetics
so first of all i just want to give you
a quick introduction of genomic vision
genomic vision is a french company based
in paris area at banyu and is the
provider of tools for molecular
conveying for the detection
visualization and characterization of
mid-range genomic rearrangements
or events and their quantification at a
single dna molecule resolution
the company has been founded in 2006 but
it really started to shift as a
commercial organization from 2019 with
the launch of the fiber vision system
and since it has been commercializing
different products
instruments and services to cover
a large number of applications with
molecular coming technology
so in this presentation we will cover
four different chapters introducing
molecular technology first so what this
technology is all about then we will see
the principle of rca in single dna
molecular resolution
then we will give some example of rca
leading towards drug discovery and
treatment refining
and finally we will see genomic visions
products and services to enable this
workflow for the characterization of
replication events
so i'd like to present you first what is
molecular combine
so the principle of molecular combing is
essentially that we are stretching dna
molecule to resolve it at high
resolution
and looking at physical and structural
variants and replication tracks we
characterize them and quantify this
feature at a single dna molecule level
you can see on the right hand side of
the slide an example of the stretched
dna that is not fluorescent
and molecular combing with fiber
technology uses constant stretching
factor to provide visualization and
quantification of single molecule dna
that can be used to quantify the lengths
and distances in genomic features
so really genomic vision has
revolutionized molecular combing to
visualize quantitative structural
features of dna for a range of
application in single molecule dna
analysis
so the principle of molecular combing is
that molecular combing helps to
characterize genomics across multiple
innovative applications such as in
genetics in cancer research genome
engineering and drug development
for the purpose of this presentation we
are going to focus on cancer research
application
as the technology gives you accurate
measurement of dna replication kinetics
as you can see on the graph here
with the origin of replication that is
pointed with the white arrows and the
replicon
was labeled in red and in green signals
and in drug development also applied
type of application as a technology
enables us to identify various features
of dna replication stress
but also
help us to validate drug candidates
through the understanding of the
replication events induced by the
treatment of the cells with anti-cancer
drugs for example like puppy inhibitor
which is shown into this example here on
the picture
so today we are then focusing on the
principle of rca replication coming
essay at a single dna molecule
resolution
so first of all we need to understand
why replication studies are important
and as we all know the dna replication
is a crucial biological process by which
dna makes a copy of itself during cell
division
during the cell life cycle the cell goes
through different phases like g1 phase
then dna replication followed by mitosis
to then give the two dosa cells with the
same genetic materials in each daughter
since dna replication happens at a
really early stage of the sales cycles
you can imagine that any problem that is
occurring at the replication level
whether this is a stop in the
replication or modification of the
replication kinetics will have an
important impact on the genome stability
and this has been shown in numerous
scientific papers as related to human
diseases including cancer
as you can see in the graft on the left
genome stability mechanism can be at a
micro level
so chromosomal integrity is protected by
centrosomal pathways in this case
or at a micro level
at the
chromatin level where the dna damage
response mechanism are protecting
chromatin from dna double strand breaks
in the oncology field one can study the
genome stability
mechanism at the micro level by studying
replication kinetics through an accurate
measurement of dna replication kinetics
but also the fundamental mechanistic of
the replication machinery involving
different dna and damage and response
pathways
and the study of the replication
inhibitors and activators but also the
replication effect of rearrangement in
target genes
this lately gives an indication of the
genome stability at the macro level
so comparing the replication events in
normal cells versus in cancer cells
using our unique replication convenience
leads to drug development as we can now
identify accurately the dna replication
stress events
we can screen the different drugs and
test their efficiency identifying and
quantifying the impact on the dna
replication and ultimately onto the
genome stability
so for this type of research studies
genomic vision with a replication coming
essay offers a clear readout of spatial
and temporal characteristics of dna
replication
rca enables
to characterize the replication events
throughout the entire genome at a single
dna molecule level
so this is an image that you can see
below generated from our fiber vision
scanner using a coverslip where the dna
samples has been labeled using our rca
protocol and combed using the fiber com
molecular calming system
you can see in the blue the
single-stranded dna is consustained with
yoyo and the replication tracks in red
and in green with incorporation of cldu
and idu respectively during the
replication
so the arrows are pointing out the
original replication so you can already
see the power of the technology
detecting the replication bubbles with a
bidirectional replication forks
at a single dna molecule resolution
so several different parameters can then
be assessed with this technology
we can assess the initiation rates the
fork velocity the fork progression
but we can also combine this technology
with fish probes
to then analyze activated origin
patterns and kinetics at a region of
interest
so now this slide walk you through the
different step of the workflow using our
replication coming essay in combination
with molecular coming platform
during the first step the dna samples
have to be treated with post labeling of
replicating cells enabling the
incorporation of two timid analog which
in this case are cldu
and idu to have a chrome or iodine that
can be used for immunodetection and
visualization later on
in the schematic here on the right hand
side
there are three origin of replication
that are represented as gray circle
and we know that in the human cells
especially the replication is
asynchronous so not all replications are
fired at the same time
here we are doing the post labeling with
each analog for 30 minutes and we start
with the first analog being cldu in red
followed by the idu in green
so in the first bubble we can see the
replication file rig has already started
before the incorporation of cldu
so we can see the origin of replication
and the red track
the second bubble show the incorporation
of cldu during the replication
firing so
there is only the red track
and in the third bubble
the cell is not replicating yet during
the first pose so there is no retract as
there is no incorporation of cldu
after the first pose we wash out the clu
and we do the second pulse without you
which then show the green track after
the red track for the bubble one and the
bubble two
and we can only see the green for the
third bubble as a replication firing
only occurred during the second pose
labeling with idu
we can then see the entire replication
track within blue the context staining
of the single-stranded dna with yoyo
and the replication tracks in red and in
green for cldu and idu
we allow the identification of the
origin of replication as well as a
timing when the replication was firing
during the 60 minute of the two
different poses
by using rca we can then have an
accurate measurement of each single
tracks in order to have precise
statistical analy analysis
so that was for the step one in the step
two after the first pers labeling we
then extract the dna with a fiber prep
kit to extract long dna molecule
in step three we then come the dna using
our fibrechord molecular calming system
and then we continue in step four with
immunodetection step consisting of using
fluorescent antibody against the timing
analogs
we finally finish with the automatic
detection and analysis of the
replication events via our fiber vision
scanner and fiber studio software
respectively
it is now possible to understand cell
viability
and specific events
only by measuring the replication
parameters
rca is then a powerful tool compared to
other technology in the lab as it can
give you seven different type of signal
depending of
the time of origin firing
like we've seen in with the bubbles in
the with the three bubbles in the
previous slides
so in the case of the initiation one
initiation one shows a replican within
the middle
you will see the replication firing
origin contest stained in blue
then the replication tracks in red and
green either side
that corresponds to the bible 1 of the
previous slide
the second bubble will then show the
initiation 2 signal where the
replication
is filed during the first pulse of cid
of cldu therefore you will see only a
red track without any blue in the middle
you will see only a red track with
either side of the green track for the
incorporation of idu
the initiation three represent the
bubble three from the previous slide
when the replication is spread during
the second pulse labeling with idu
and with molecular combing you can also
detect
three types of termination signal when
the bubble goes back together on the
other end
and in case of the first bubble you
would see the turmeric termination one
with the only one
red truck as we consider that the green
truck are fused together
as a replication has been resolved
for the second bubble
the green trucks are closing together
then followed by the red truck
and this is the termination two
and then for the third bubble
determination three
uh with the grid tracks
taking not completely joining
they are not completely joining they
will take time to join but you will see
the and therefore you will see the blue
dna signal in the middle
in some cases we can also see the
unidirectional fork
showing one green and red track as yours
green and red cross track are so far
away on the dna fiber that is considered
as unidirectional
so rca simplifies to uncover
complex replication kinetics
that are difficult to review and to
reveal since the asynchronous
nature of the replication
so the replication combination rca
addresses various questions about
replication on individual dna fibers in
a single experiment
so just to remember for the dna analysis
we only take the intact signals and
discard the dna break
that could have occurred during the
stretching forces of the dna
and for that reason it's very important
like i mentioned in the previous slide
that we see the blue either side the
blue signal either side of the replican
in green and red
so the replication coming assay allows
us to look at the fork velocity
and the progression as well as the folk
stalling by establishing the ratio of
signal cldu idu
if we consider that the pulse is the
same
it's during the same time
for cldu and idu
if we see that this ratio is equal to
one then we will consider that is an
imperative replication
with uh the signal in the red
is equal
to the signal in the green
now if we see that this ratio cldu idu
is reduced is less than one
this will show a slower replication and
in the in the picture here we can see
that the green track is
shorter than the red track showing that
there's a smaller incorporation of igu
we can also identify with accuracy the
length of the replication track so the
replicated dna on the whole dna fiber
due to the constant stretching factor on
our fibrocar molecular coming system
and then we can study the initiation
right which is effectively the number of
activated origin on the total length of
dna molecule
so just to give you an example for rca
at the beginning of the experiment we
recommend to use 30 000 cells per cover
sleep and this generates in average 3000
signals of replicated dna on the whole
coverslip
so the constant stretching factor is
also important for the precise
measurement of the forks
in order to see the folk symmetry
you can see in the image on the left
that the replication track in red and
green is longer than the replication
track on the other side showing that
there's an asymmetry of the fork
in the case of full styling we can see
that the replication track on the right
side
is lacking the green signal
and this indicates that the replication
has stopped
lastly but not least as we can identify
the original replication and measure
precisely the length of the dna
fibers we can also calculate the
inter-origin distance and
inter-termination distance so the entire
origin distance
being the distance between the different
origin firing of replication
this information is actually really
important mainly when we do drug
development studies
and we want to check the firing of
origin of replication that can be
increased
after drug treatment
with inter-origin distance becoming
shorter
so the iod we call it anti-origin is an
iod becoming shorter
and with a panoramic visualization of
the replication events at a single dna
molecule level
rca and molecular combing offer then a
really clear readout of spatial
and temporal characteristics of dna
replication
so you can already see from the
different parameters and the images that
we've just seen in the previous slide
that rca with molecular combing gives a
clear advantages in comparison to
classical methods
on each clover sleep long dna fibers up
to three megabases
will be stretched uniformly and parallel
allowing more data to be exploited than
other classical methods where fibers
often cross each other's and are then
discarded from the analyses
as you can see on the right hand side
you can see a picture of the parallel
dna fibers obtained with our fiber
vision scanner
and versus at the bottom with classical
method where the dna fibers crosses each
other's
rca with molecular combing and our fiber
vision scanner offer high resolution
data allowing the detection of rare
events and with the constant stretching
factor we can determinate iod and itd as
well as fox symmetry whereas it is not
possible with classical methods like
fiber spreading
fibervision scanner with also the fiber
studio software and very soon the
integration of artificial intelligence
software enable the automatic detection
and characterization of the replication
events making the data analysis very
robust and standardized and reducing the
time to results
so genomic vision with a replication
coming assay and the molecular coming
technology and platform
covers all the steps leading to success
from sample preparation to data analysis
in four different steps
first of all the sample preparation with
rca and dna extraction with the fiber
prep kits
using 30 000 cells per coverslip
then the dna combing is done on the
fibricom molecular coming system to
stretch the dna fibers
then the staining is done and the
coverslip are then scanned
on the fibervision scanner for the
detection of the signals and data
analysis is done on the fiber studio
software resulting in a report for each
coverslip and each sample
we then move to the third chapter of
this presentation that focuses more on
the application of rca so replication
coming essay for the use of drug
discovery and treatment refining
so when we study dna damage reaper
pathways specific biomarkers have been
identified as target for potential
anti-cancer treatments
and these biomarkers are involved in
different dna repair pathways such as
non-mucus and joining or monocultural
combination and other pathways the most
common is pop inhibitor um so pop one
pathways
uh with pop inhibitor and
but there's also other pathways with
bracket 1
being 1 and rod 51.
these pathways are using the replication
machinery so the effect of the drug can
be monitored and quantified by rca and
molecular coming at a single dna
molecule resolution
so if you want to screen different drugs
and study the efficiency of the drug
knowing the target of the drug there are
different ways to design the experiment
so for example for studying replication
kinetics you can do the drug treatment
for the entire experiment even during
the two purse labeling
or in between the two pearls and then
look at the fork progression
in this case if you do the treatment
after the first purse you can see the
progression of the green track
for treated versus entranced cells
and see a shorter track on the right
hand side indicating a slower
replication
or if you focus on restart of the
replication studies
in this case the drug is administrated
during the first purse then washed away
with like
something like hydroxyurea
or you can do the drug treatment in
between the two parts for a period of
time then wash away the drug
you can see the green truck shorter than
the run track as the replication
restarted
or you can see stalled fork with only
the red truck
or new origin with only the green truck
and finally you can also do resection
studies where the drug will bring you to
the reverse fork
and in this case the cells are treated
with a drug after the two pulses
if there is resection the exonuclease
activity of the replication machinery
will take off the dntps of the idu truck
and you will see the green truck shorter
than the red truck
this is applicable for many biomarkers
many drugs like pop inhibitor and if
there is resistance to the purp
the resection studies may be analyzed or
can be checked on the new firing origin
and this is the case for all biomarkers
being anti-cancer drugs
so this is an example of the use of
molecular common technology with rca for
new anti-cancer therapeutic strategy
bracket 1 2 and right 51 play major role
in replication fork stabilization
following the replication stress by
preventing nucleolytic degradation of
replication forks by the nuclease mre11
and in this paper dr saanice and her
team wanted to investigate the effect of
cx 5461 on fork stabilization
uh in
ovcr a
r8 cells
nascent replication tracks were first
labeled with cldu then idu before
treatment with
cx5461 for three hours
they then looked at the replication fork
progression by measuring the itu truck's
length
and we can see on the graph here that
with the cx-5461
the idu track is shorter indicating that
cx-5461 treatment causes an overall
decrease in tracklands
as you can see in a graph also with a
red plot
this suggests the degradation of
replication forks upon induction of
dna damage and repair by cx-5461
and this was rescued by co-treatment
with the mre 11 inhibitor which is
called mirin confirming the inhibition
that the inhibition of the mre 11
nuclease can rescue cx
5461 mediated fork destabilization
as you can see in the plot in green and
in blue
in the second graph so on the right
uh they then assessed
whether dna damage induced by cx 5461
treatment affects folk progression by
pre-treating cells with cx 5461 for 24
hours then post labels with both analogs
pre-treatment with
cx5461 had no effect on the fork pro
lengths uh suggesting that cx-5461
does not cause any lesion that could
impact fork restarting or progression
as you can see in the red plot that is
no different from the control plot in
the gray
on the other end
the poppy uh
pop inhibitor sotalazo parib
which is called in this case bmn 673
increases increased fall progression
and this was confirmed
that this was confirming that uh
papinibiter mediated acceleration of
fork illustration is a mechanism for
replication stress and dna damage
as you can see on the with the bmn 673
plot in green
and later on with the
the the blue plot with cx-5461
so to conduct these experiments genomic
visions offers an end-to-end solution
with product and services so that you
can have the choice to
either
conduct the experiment in your lab at
your own speed or simply send the plugs
or samples to generic vision for
servicing
so there are three types of consumables
that are required for the sample
preparation
the fiber prep kit is used for the
extraction step and the preparation of
the plugs
so it ensures high molecular weight dna
from hundred kb to two to three
megabases and you can use it with whole
blood cells or pelleted cells from cell
culture
there are two formats for this kit so
for 10 samples or 400 samples and
depending on the format of the kids that
you will go for the storage and shipment
will be different so for example for the
fiber prep keep 10
there this is cheap at 4 degree and for
the fiber prep kit 100 there will be one
part shipped with dry ice which will
then need to be stored at minus 20 and
the other part at four degree
then for dna coming step you would then
need to use a single
well single use disposable reservoirs
that fits the fiber comm molecular
coming systems
and these reservoirs
are a single use sterile and dna dns
frame
then finally the engraved cover slip are
strictly quality checked and make sure
that dna binds from the extremities and
give reproducibility and robustness to
the combing of the dna and dna affinity
for the combing of the dna onto the
coverslip like i mentioned we have our
fiber co-molecular calming system
and this system allows the stretching of
the entire genome uniformly and
continuously
in a 10-minute procedure
so
the the advantage of this system is
really that dna molecules size are
between 100 kb and 2 to 3 megabases
which is very long for dna fibers
but it's mainly
the fact that it allows parallel
alignment of single dna molecule due to
the constant stretching factor
and dna extremities are not chemically
modified
so for the scan of the com coverslip you
can use either the fiber vision of all
the fibervision s scanner
both scanners have the high the same
high resolution at 0.16 micron per pixel
and can allow a quick automated scan of
60 minutes per coverslip
now the main difference between the two
scanners it's the stamper storage and
the channels
as you can see the fibre vision allows a
160 sample storage with permanent
loading
and there is three channels for
simultaneous three-color labeling
now the fiber vision s
offers a more flexibility and
versatility of the the applications as
it has nine channels colors
but the slide storage is a bit less with
a 12 slide storage and automatic slide
loading
so for the data analysis part
we use our fiber studio analysis
software and this software allows the
detection analysis and interpretation of
hybridization signals on com dna in a
streamlined computer assisted process
essentially you can see a photo of the
software in the on the right hand side
and you can see each of the event is
boxed in
then you will you can visualize the
events so the replicant in red and in
green on the right hand side
and then you can validate this event so
there's a possible manual correction of
automatic measurements
at the end of the the analysis that's an
automated report creation and
downloadable raw data
and the sensitivity of the software
it's so high that it enables the
detection of unexpected features
and it's available for structural
variation and dna replication analysis
now to complete this software
genomic vision is also
launching very soon a new software with
artificial intelligence
which will
completely characterize all the events
automatically and generate directly all
the report without having to
manually check
each of the events to validate the
characterization of these events
so now genomic vision offers also the
possibility to send out your samples to
service to our service in-house
so for that you can prepare your samples
with a fiber prep kit to prepare the
plugs of agarose and send these plugs to
our service
for the extraction combing hybridization
and image acquisition with the easycom
service and then the team will send you
the raw data to analyze on your site
otherwise you can also incorporate the
analysis part by choosing the easy
complex service
now if you have already got the fiber
comp
molecular calming system in your lab
you can do the preparation of the
samples and comb the dna onto the
coverslips and send us a comp cover slip
for servicing by choosing the easy scan
and then you can carry on the
the data analysis on your site
or if you want to have the reporting
as well as a scanning then you can
choose also the easy scan plus service
there are numerous scientific papers
that have been published showing the use
of fiber vision platform with rca to
better understand the events of dna
replication in different pathways
and how they are impacted after cells
treatment with different drugs here you
can see an example of five different
platforms dna fiber analysis mind the
gap has been published in 2017
the other ones are more recent with two
the two last papers scientific report
and molecular cells that have been
published last year
so as a summary molecular coming with
the fiber vision platform and rca
provides an easy and complete solution
to understand the replication kinetics
this technology is the only tool
enabling to better understand the
efficiency of the replication by various
parameters
such as replication speed fork symmetry
inter-origin distance iod
inter-termination
distance itd and the number of
applications other classical methods
would be compromised in some para some
of these parameters
rca can be combined with various
compounds against specific biomarkers to
better discriminate the efficacy on
specific pathways and it's also an
external biomarker for understanding and
quantifying
the possible drug targets and its
efficiency
and in all of this
fiber studio and our fiber vision
platform
allows to detect all these parameters
and to analyze the data with more
efficient and standardized
quantification
and it's also allowing us
a faster data analysis
reducing the time to results
thank you very much for your attention
and i will take now any questions
thank you
thank you cindy for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the number of cells required for
the experiment
so uh for replication combing essay we
normally use 30 000 cells
at the beginning of the experiment
and this leads us to
generate
an average between five and
and fifteen thousand
uh signals back oversleep
okay thank you
next question
why in the report do we get only the
initiation 1 termination 3 and
unidirectional events
so the simple reason to that is that
we have we need to border actually the
replicon with the blue signal for the
single-stranded dna
uh in the case of initiation two and
termination two for example where the
firing of the
the replication is happening during the
the second pose
sorry during the first pose
um we will not be able to distinguish
the focal asymmetry so we will be able
to give only the extremity colors for
the fork speed but not the forecast
symmetry so this will be um not reliable
and this is why uh we only use
replication initiation one and
termination three as well as
unidirectional
uh signals for the for the reports
generated at the end
thank you
our next question is how many signals
can be detected on a cover slip using
rca and 30 000 cells
so so yeah so it's uh quite variable
depending on to the the cell type that
you are using
and depending on the density of the
fibers obviously but uh in general this
is between five and fifteen thousand uh
signal per coverslip
all right
and our last question is which brands of
ab do you use for cldu and idu we've
found none that are truly specific since
the original brand was discontinued in
2017.
yes so
since a few years now we use other
brands
to
to
replace the brand that has been
discontinued
and for the cldu we use the apcam and
for the idu we use bd bioscience as a
brand for the antibody
well great thank you again cindy for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor genomic vision for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
thank you
thank you to all and goodbye bye thank
you
you